we're in the call 8 phone bank answering
your questions about medicare enrollment
and if you have any questions this is
really the time to call these good folks
are going to be here until 7 tonight but
usually during this 3 o'clock hour the
phone calls are not as frequent as they
are as the evening progresses but to
answer some more questions we're joined
by rick scroggs with alignment health
plan thanks for being here thanks
kendall appreciate it this window of
enrollment is about to close yeah we're
just about here so tuesday december 7th
ends annual enrollment but the message
here is that it's not too late we
brought this whole team of local agents
in who live here in las vegas to answer
their questions to help them so i don't
want them to think oh no i forgot it's
too late i want them to really take
advantage of this that's why we have
them here today why is it so important
for everyone even if they have an
existing plan to
ask questions and to look into their
plan uh during this period of time yeah
it's it's interesting you know
throughout the year a lot can happen so
a lot of times it's our health it
changes it's our circumstances it could
be that the plans have changed and
they're just a little bit different
these professional agents are the ones
who know all the plans and they can kind
of help them understand them and make
sure that they've got the very best
thing they can they don't want to go a
whole another year and not have the plan
that's right for them terrific all right
rick thanks so much for your help thanks
for the folks who remain in the phones
today
650-1101 is the number to call they're
going to be here until 7 but really take
advantage of this little window we have
here right now and they'll answer all
your questions about medicare enrollment